have you ever used anal beads while
playing chess you know your curiosity is
a bit concerning you know maybe you're
personally interested but uh I can tell
you no
prove that you've used anal beads to
cheat
how can I you know that is not a serious
Theory okay that was something that the
media caught up it is an unequivocal
fact that I have never treated an
over-the-board game yeah I'm just
wondering how do you disprove it I mean
were you strip searched did they explore
cavities where do we go here through
tournaments there are security checks
metal detectors different scanners would
that pick up anal beads we don't know
the answer to that question Pierce maybe
you can ask the anal B people have them
on your show and they can explain it to
you better and will you allow yourself
to be strip searched just to rule out
any rumors I find that question to be
just you know I can't take you seriously
when you ask those questions I'm sorry
do you think when you play Magnus Carson
again you'll kick his butt for one of a
better phrase you know I'll just let my
chest pick for itself